hi and welcome to Google developers live
I'm mark McDonald and I'm with Josh have
been here from the Maps developer
relations team today we're going to
start talking about Google Maps engine
and a couple of new features we've got
on the end points of you Josh thanks
mark yeah so Google Maps engine some of
you might be familiar is a kind of easy
way to create share publish maps and put
data into a Google cloud so what we're
going to cover today are a couple of
endpoints that create and upload
endpoints to show you how to
programmatically get data in and why
don't we start out by looking at a demo
so this first demo is of a Python sample
that's hosted using Google's App Engine
I will load it up straight away and get
straight into it we start off with
looking at some projects you'll have
attached to your account so you can
group your your different mapping
projects into into sort of logical
groupings called projects we with this
demo we simply just upload a shapefile
shapefile as a zip file of a bunch of
sort of component files that form some
some vector data in a table format we
can provide a description and some tags
to describe our table if we want to find
it later using the api's and then we can
just go ahead and upload it
okay so it turns out this is probably
not about kittens will just put state
borders hit upload and what will happen
in the back end here is we're creating a
sort of skeleton asset saying what files
are going to be involved in the upload
uploading the individual files and then
getting back a status for maps engine
which we can see on the screen so what
yeah once that that status is said
processed and we're ready to go we'll
get it we'll get a link showing us on on
the page which can send us back to the
maps engine web interface we'll be able
to preview of the vector data that's
been uploaded as you can see here
there's a little block up a little blue
outlined which show show the data that
we did upload everything's been
successful so that's all good yeah and
if I go ahead and refresh this page over
here we should see that the processing
status is complete usually takes a few
seconds gives us some metadata back
about the data that we uploaded so
that's the kind of example that you
might want to build so that people can I
use your workflow to get the data in
this code is available on github you can
download it at the link below for kit
modify it user doesn't starting point
for working with App Engine and ooofff
and the syntax for uploading data to
maps engine and if you've got any
opportunities for improvement that you
think we'd like to know about feel free
to send them away we love getting pull
requests indeed we do so let's go ahead
and walk through a little bit more
detail the code and kind of the flow of
getting data in with this second example
here which you can download as part of
our Python client library so if you go
and look for the Google API Python
client there's a bunch of samples and in
the samples to the maps engine sample
that we'll walk through you can just
download the zip or clone the project to
get this sample so on the first run with
a sample like this it right walks
through an OAuth flow just to find out
who you are and make sure you've got
permission to access the data I will
skip straight past sap but before you
get started on your own project if even
if you're running this sample you'll
you'll need to go ahead and get a API
key and set up a project on Google's API
console before you'll be able to start
this there's more docs on
developers.google.com/live so as part
art setting up that
develop a console project you'll get an
API key and you can at that point
download the client secrets which you
can see that I have put into my samples
folder here let's climb sequence JSON
and once I have that in there I can go
ahead and run my sample and what it will
do is create an authorized request to
the project endpoint get me back a list
of projects I'm going to pick a project
here like this one that I have access to
get the ID of the project and pass that
in as an argument projects argument run
the script again and what you can see
flying by you on the screen up here is
the skeleton asset that we're creating
it's going through and now uploading
each file individually down here and
then pulling for the processing status
to see how that upload is doing and
that's exactly the same process that we
went through in the previous demo just
on the command line right and now that
we have a little five-second wait here
if would say successfully processed give
us the table ID back and now why don't
we go ahead and take a look at the
actual code when Josh first run the
program earlier it was just a list
project which basically just uses this
simple get request to this URL you can
see below it's it's as simple as it
looks it is a get request we don't need
any parameters we just take the JSON
response it comes back from the server
and we log it straight to the output
once we've done that we want to upload a
shapefile so that was the second run
through the Josh did it takes the the
upload URL below which is a slash tables
endpoint and basically before we can
start uploading data we need to create
an empty table assets so down here we go
through each of the shapefile suffixes
that we're going to use which which map
to each of the the corresponding shape
component files are in in the the zip
file we use and create an empty metadata
structure which describes the table that
we're about to start uploading once we
push this to the server we get back an
ID which corresponds to the table that
we're going to use to upload content
each other when we do each of the
shapefiles and also when we go to poll
the server later
so then we go straight into the file
suffixes and upload them straight to the
the endpoint we use before just with a
slash files on the end and push the
service straight up to the push shows
file straight up to the server once
that's done we use the idea we got back
from the original request to do a to
check on the table status and make sure
that everything's all good awesome
thanks for the walkthrough that looks
pretty straightforward just to summarize
it we're going to go ahead and go
through the OAuth workflow which happens
like magic in the Python samples for you
but we end up with an authorized HTTP
request and then we go ahead and post a
sort of skeleton asset which says these
are the files we're going to be putting
in these are the different tags
description and name of the project and
once we post that we get back an ID we
use that ID to go ahead and push the
various files in pull for the processing
status and we're done
and the cool thing is this works very
similarly for images so for example if
you're uploading a geo-referenced image
you can have that PNG for example in the
sidecar file that has the world extent
ended the exact same pattern a couple
other details like you might be
including some additional things like
that date on the image but generally the
same pattern and then in addition we
have a create endpoint so you can create
an empty vector table without having to
have an existing shape file or a CSV or
KML or anything like that and then just
push data into it later using the insert
endpoint so go ahead and check out these
code samples yeah they're available on
on github and if you've got any
questions about it you can either ask in
the comments or jump on Stack Overflow
there's a big community of users there
who happy to help you out and good luck
if you have any more questions I guess
there's documentation we can check out
on developers.google.com but have fun
cheers guys until next time
you